so I'm coming to generate um there is
the AL key there is a key I'm coming to
generate this key to program the car the
car the client bought the car brand new
so a used car so he wants me
to give him another key so that even if
they have spare key they can't move the
car so I'll do all key loss and add two
keys to the system so you can see this
ID 47
this ID 47 so I'm coming to generate the
key and I have to test the frequency
also to know the kind of frequency the
vehicle is
using so let me do the
test this 4 ter um Sorry 4 teritory
yeah so I'll know the kind of key to
generate for the system so now as I know
the chip ID and
the course now I know the chip because
now I know the chip ID I know the car
I'm working with so it's
Honda and I have to do all KY losw for
the client so
that
CRV I really don't know the year so I'll
choose 2019 or 2018
and you can see the key start from 2017
to 2020 and it is 433 and it is the same
key type it is the same key type so I'll
place it here with the remote in
it so I'll place it here with the remote
in it then let me continue this is the
key that I want to generate so let me do
generate and for my for my km 100 I
misplaced my
I misplaced
my VCI so now I have to buy new VCI
before I can use the km 100 so I'm using
it for only key generation because if I
use the programmer I have to get um 12
volt power supply to it and I don't want
to go through that stress so with this
one what I'll do is I'll wait for it to
finish
generating for it to finish generating
the
key but for now it has to upgrade the
key so if you can see it upgrade it then
after the upgrade it's now upgrading the
key boot loader before it's going to
before it to generate the key it has to
do all these things before it will
generate the original key for me to use
so I think it is done with the boot
loader so it's now detecting the key and
it's now generating the universal key
which will take almost a minute
which is 60
seconds so I'll just wait for it to
finish with the key
generation so these are the new keys
that I've bought to do this kind of
works so that if my clients buy new
vehicles and they don't really trust one
or two things I raise all the keys and
add another key for them to secure the
car for them so that no one can just
come and drive the car and move because
it's something they do a lot they will
sell the key to they will sell the card
to you and give you one key then later
in the days or maybe in months they will
come and drive the car off and move away
if you don't register it even if you
register they do that so I'll do this
key for my clients then I'll go and do
the programming or key lost but I'll be
using the IM uh the IM 60 because i' I
don't have my VCI with me if I had the
VCI complete if I had the VCI I could
have just used my VCI to do the
programming so let me read the key ID
and see if it is ID
47 yeah it is ID 47 it is not locked so
go back again
and exit and go to frequency and test
the frequenc frequency and make sure the
frequency matches the original
key yeah 433 and there is the original
key for the vehicle that one also is
433 yeah and this one also is
433 yeah so I'll add the
key then I'll call it the fix thank you
for watching subscribe to my channel for
more videos so the ignition is able to
turn on because I have the two keys this
is the new one I'm programming you can
see the difference this is the new one
that I'm programming and this is the
original vehicle key so let me go to
emo
and so that's at this point we have the
original
key so
let me it's a smart key it is pushed to
start just select
this so I didn't select let me do the
emot
scan then T me to press it twice but I
don't need to do that because the
ignition is already on so you just SC
the system and it has two keys in the
system but my client has only one key so
only one key was given to my client so
what I'm going to do is erase that key
and add this key to the system so that
um they might not have any key to come
and start the car or anything so
straight to the point let me go to all
key lost and start and follow the
instructions okay turn off the ignition
so you turn it off or do I have all the
keys so what I can do is place the keys
let's see placed L
key
yeah so I'm starting with original key
so it's only the original key in the car
so it asks me to turn the key on by
pressing twice so let me do one two it
turns it on so we have the keys we have
the original key in the car but the
ignition is on now so wait for the
machine to do it thing and
now
yes connecting to
internet wow wow wow with that internet
connection it will not
work so now I've have connected it to
the internet you can see my Wi-Fi signal
so we wait for the next stage
so wait for it to finish with the
communication issue because it is going
to erase all the
key yeah so it is done we wait for
checking
vehicle we wait for the whole process to
be done yes key programming successible
yes I have another
key m
place outlo and place in so let me do so
now I bring the other key that I want to
program in the car then click on
okay
okay place the next key to be Lear
in so I'll wait and
see let's keep programming successful do
you have any other key no I don't have
any other
key so now please switch
off yes the ignition is off so I wait
for a prompt to turn the ignition on
turn the ignition
on yes the ignition is turned
on yes so let me
bring yeah there there is no indicator
lamp
so let me test
it there's no indicator
lamp yes it is stand on so let me bring
the other key in but before that let me
finish with the process
first let me bring the other key in
again to so now I have the two keys in
the car so let me turn on the ignition
yeah so the ignition is turned on it's
checking the vehicle
System complete please switch it off now
it is off check if to so you can see
when I
press it works so let me try this one
also yeah so that means the two keys
work let me try this one
again yeah
okay let me try this one also
again yeah so this one has the key
holder so both of them work and this one
also yeah so now everything is done
successful yeah and let me open the door
and turn on the ignition so that it will
pass this
stage so that means the two keys are
programmed successfully so I'm done
thank you for watching subscribe to my
channel for more
videos so there's an error that just
happened I think my a crashed but the
programming is done
successfully yeah so both keys can start
the car so what I'll do is let me turn
it off take one key out from the
car take this original key out of the
car and leave this new one in
okay so there is the new one yeah so it
works let me start the car with it yeah
so the vehicle is running that tells me
that the key programming is done
successfully so let me turn it off and
bring the so this is the original key
for the car so let me start
it okay and the vehicle is running so
that means my key programming is done
successfully thank you for watching
subscribe to my channel for more videos